Starry Messenger yes yes
perspectives on civilization Neil you
call this a wake-up to civilization wake
up call wake up call it's a civilization
yeah um embracing a cosmic perspective
what does that mean it means there's so
much of what we do on Earth that we get
so embedded in our own
uh personal belief systems even when
they they
they don't match what is objectively
true but we fight over these things
right but if you take a step back add a
little bit a dose of science okay and
science thinking and especially a cosmic
perspective often many of those problems
just evaporate we're sitting there
arguing but there's another perch we
could occupy look back and say no we
weren't really arguing about anything
yeah and so the book I collected a life
of observations ever since I was
scientifically literate early middle
school right watching adults say things
do things it's like what did you just
say yeah
yourself as a nerdy kid honestly this
has been you from the time you were a
little boy but I like what you said if
an alien landed on in our country and
said take me to your leader should they
go to the white house or should they go
to the National Academy of Science and
you seem to think not it's not a bad
idea to go to the National Academy of
Science because scientists who say are
uniquely qualified to do what to where
because we think about problems we
strive to think about problems without
bias without preconceived notions with
that we don't always accomplish that but
that is the goal and so look at the data
if an alien comes to take it to your
leader are you are you really going to
take them to the White House take them
to somebody who's thought about this
problem okay so who also knows that's
mathematics is a language of the
universe yes right right they're not
going to come here and speak Mandarin or
English or French no they're going to
have some other thing I'm going to look
for the periodic table of elements on
their wall for example that's something
that applies Across the Universe digits
of pi you know things that will Empower
you to communicate with them so in the
book with all the social issues I
address I throw in an alien every now
and then just to see what they would say
he also say would be it's not good for a
scientist in Vegas it's not good it's
not good for Vegas when scientists go oh
yeah well this is actually my favorite
part of the book but you actually Gamble
from time to time yes oh yeah I'll get
that just one quick second so the
American physical society which is the
the Society of physicists yeah in the
country those are your homies my people
my people and stuff so they were going
to have a conference in in San Diego
hotels didn't work out Vegas said come
here we got rooms they all went after a
week the headline was
physicist in town lowest Casino take
ever oh okay
they were never invite it back because
we understand the frailties of the human
mind and why we have no capacity to
think statistically and
probabilistically about this world you
and and the saddest sentence I wrote in
that book was because we can't think
rationally about statistics their whole
industries that rise up to exploit that
yeah and they're called Casino yeah so
you're saying you and the other guys
were bringing down the house yeah
I don't remember if this was in my
forbidden Twitter file but uh
what I want to say is I think the state
lotteries
are attacks on people who never did well
in mathematics State Lottery now uh
we'll talk during the commercial break
but you said the future holds
self-driving electric vehicles will
fully replace cars mental illness will
be cured um cancer will be cured and we
will learn how to regrow Limbs and
failing organs I'm telling you by 2050
out the books
thank you so much
go get the book it is great we need this
right now